son personnage de râleurs à l' accent
yiddish et à jamais un monument de
l'humour français
vous pourrez le retrouver notamment le 2
octobre à la salle jacques brel à
montigny le bretonneux avec son
spectacle intitulé c'est la dernière
fois
voici popeck dans le kiosque on n'est
pas des sauvages tout de même nom alors
il va chanter une chanson qui apporte un
message c'est à dire que ça s'adresse
pas à n'importe qui ça s'adresse à ma
part
que c'est une santé ça s'appelle pour le
constater
mais faire des histoires pour un cordon
des rideaux non mais sans blague
pourquoi je suis revenue petit parce que
35 ans après avoir créé ce personnage je
suis en harmonie eric avec l'âge que
j'ai composé à l'époque ça nous est ça
il sent rien la maison il me glisser
abidal et à force de tourner en rond
dans son bocal idées menèrent bastelica
alors j'ai la sorte à la campagne au gré
des mots bis a peiné nageoires pour
qu'ils jouent avec les copines au moins
un ciré prend des couleurs
on n'est pas des sauvages sont
maintenant lorsque mon père me disait
toujours que j'étais un sauvage pense
que jamais on ne l'accent de mon père
et comme il était très bavard bon
messier pour aller au jardin
d'acclimatation semeta pas besoin
demandé papa regarde on le voit le
diable d'habitants ont fait part de la
personne et un sauvage voilà chômage
c'est moi et moi ça ça n'a ni queue ni
tête un match comme ça quoi
j'ai passé 10 canard eager ça pourrait
faire un masque anti policiers ont
regardé pour ça faut avoir le kid
roulement gonflé pour mettre un match
comme ça quoi c'est mon matériel à mon
talent mais avant c'était là qu'il
quitta j'ai les fesses
maintenant c'est les fesses qui
taquinent haute alors je n'ai jamais
jamais écrit sur l'actualité tout ce que
j'ai fait ce sont des accidents de
parcours
par exemple un type dans le fond de la
salle des criées un jour jeudi
y at il un violoniste dans la salle de
quelqu'un qui a crié way la façon dont
on a dit haut et ça m'a appelé parce que
si c'est ouais c'est pas un jeu c'est
que c'est pas un violoniste un enjeu les
dix ans nous a rien demandé
j'ai dit on vous entend et toute la
salle a éclaté de rire
le lendemain j'ai fait dans une autre
ville j'ai dit à mon régisseur tu vas me
dire la même chose au même moment parce
que ce rire que j'ai obtenu ce soir là
ça beau dehors et at-il un violoniste
dans la salle
oui j'ai fait un bep et j'ai tout
compris et j'ai dit à mon régisseur tu
sais pourquoi pas ce que tu as fait oui
et oui c'est un violoniste alors que si
tu m'avais dit oui
le soir ils attirent vers lee dans la
salle ouais on nous a rien demandé bave
mais voilà le mystère la magie c'est ça
ça c'est un stradivarius chinoise
que j'ai acheté à charlton quartier
chinoise et la porte d'italie à paris
sinon s'il y en a qui n'aiment pas les
violons dans dégoûté par les autres
y en a qui écoute ici quand même là où
alors avant oui alors j'ai perdu la
nôtre maintenant vient d'annoncer croyez
que j'entends pas ce que vous dites
les jeux séries c'est le corde c'est
vous qui allez payer les cordes
j'ai toujours eu peur ça c'est une
maladie chez moi une maladie
malheureusement une malade malade il
angoisse et un manque de confiance
c'est pas croyable un manque de
confiance en moi et c'est toujours été
donc c'est ce manque de confiance s'est
manifestée autrefois par une agressivité
qui étaient des défauts qui sont devenus
les qualités parce que des gens aient
reçu aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quand
j'arrive sur une scène les gens
m'applaudissent avant même que je
commence à parler
donc c'est difficile d'être agressif
mais à l'époque il y avait un silence
dans la salle
et moi contrairement à barbara ou des
grands chanteurs qui aime le silence
dans la salle
moi si l'entente n'est pas un mois avant
j'étais très entier ah c'est une femme
de caractère à la fin de l'année au son
à la porte c'était les pompiers elle
crie à travers la porte qu'est ce qui se
passe ce qu'elle fait norma dames c'est
pour les étrennes
ah bon alors glissé l'est sous la porte
bon on dirait que c'est quand même une
femme fidèle je vous répondrai qu'une
femme fidèle
c'est une femme qui n'aime pas faire
souffrir plusieurs sommes à la fois et
qui s'acharne sur un sel
sur scène dans un petit théâtre où je
passais avant que je passe sur scène il
dit c'est à vous popeck amusez vous bien
jeudi je te donner un bon conseil ne dit
jamais un vrai comique
amusez vous bien à ce qu'on s'amuse pas
ce sont les indécis qui s'amuse ce sont
les amuseurs prend 2 et banquet mais un
vrai comique ne s'amuse pas un vrai
clown ne s'amuse pas ils amusent les
autres quand vous lui enlevez le masque
et du pas amusant à qui elle est et
qu'elle était créée l'été
râpez petite amie avec laquelle j'étais
à qualité qu'elle était qu'hériter
qu'elle était calé tech
il était moche
mais maintenant nouvelle formule de ce
kiosque qui deviendra hebdomadaire dès
le mois prochain
on retrouve un sujet de la rédaction
avec l'excellente avec la charmante que
dis-je avec l'extraordinaire johanna
soudry qui nous parle des affiches de
pierre allait sauter les chances qui
pardon exposé en ce moment à guyancourt
en septembre tout le monde reprend le
rythme pas d'exception pour la salle
d'exposition de guyancourt qui accueille
les travaux de l'artiste belge pierre
alechinsky c'est une exposition qui n'a
jamais été montré en ile de france ni en
région ni à paris et parce que c'est une
exposition hockey le peintre graveur
dessinateur illustrateur quelle échéance
qui tient auquel il tient beaucoup
pour la simple et bonne raison que son
travail d'affichiste il le conçoit comme
un vrai travail d'artiste
pour lui c'est une matière à
expérimentation plus de 50 ans d'affiche
retracé en une exposition 110 oeuvres
qui aborde l'amour de l'artiste pour
l'imprimerie des illustrations pour de
grands événements sportifs culturels ou
littéraire certains motifs reviennent
comme le cobra un groupe d'artistes
venus de copenhague bruxelles et
amsterdam
la roue de l'imprimerie le volcan sans
oublier quelques lithographies comme une
ouverture et une invitation à la galerie
lelong de paris qui accueille des
dernières oeuvres de l'artiste belge
on vous invite également à venir voir
les verts participer aux visites guidées
que nous proposons une visite guidée qui
aura lieu le samedi 22 septembre à 11
heures visite guidée de cette exposition
par marie houssin qui est chargée des
estampes à la galerie lelong et pour les
plus courageux ont les accompagnera
également à la galerie lelong à paris
pour découvrir donc la nouvelle
exposition d'alechinsky sans oublier le
samedi 29 septembre une collaboration
avec la maison de la poésie une lecture
rencontre avec salah stétié qui est un
poète et écrivain qui a collaboré de
nombreuses fois avec alechinsky et qui
vient faire
là une lecture dans ce lieu ici un petit
peu particulier l'univers de l'artiste
belge est à découvrir dans la salle
d'exposition de guyancourt jusqu'au 14
octobre
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
d'aller ranger votre kitesurf au garage
le 28 septembre juliette gréco sera au
prisme à l encours les 28 et 29
septembre le chorégraphe angelin
prejlocaj présentera ce que j'appelle
oublis au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le 29
septembre ouverture de saison festive à
l'estaminet avec jean pierre drouet
adoula la fraise et jérôme thomas
les 4 5 et 6 octobre emmanuelle béart
s'illustrera dans la pièce se trouvait
de stanislas nordey au théâtre de saint
quentin en yvelines tandis que le 6
octobre les rois de la suède se
produiront en concert à la merise
attrape des dates que vous pouvez
retrouver ainsi que l'ensemble de la
programmation culturelle des salles
saint-quentinoise dans le kiosque sur
internet aux adresses qui s'affiche
alors bon spectacle à tous et à bientôt